wednesday edition pft live pftpm
hiatus style plenty of things to discuss
in the nfl even though training camps
still aren't open i saw a tweet earlier
today of
ben roethlisberger showing up not
latrobe in pittsburgh remember they're
not going back to saint vincent college
this year the nfl wouldn't allow it but
the cowboys
and the steelers and the buccaneers
opening up this week next week
everyone else there will be more and
more news but even with
the vast majority of the nfl still in
hibernation
there's plenty of news and let's begin
with tom brady the buccaneers
quarterback yesterday at the white house
a couple of funny lines couple of jokes
i'm not going to talk about that though
we've already written about it and there
really isn't much more to say other than
he may need to hire a slightly better
team of writers
the jokes were good not great i'd give
him maybe a 7.5 out of 10
could have done better should have
farmed that out to someone other than
whoever he farmed it out
too that said he had a a town hall
recently
with jim gray it looks more like a
fireside chat with a crappy gas
log over his shoulder a lot of topics
that brady discussed during that now
that town hall goes live later today i
believe
but some things that we've written about
at pft
uh first of all on the topic of who the
unnamed mother effer was remember the
comment from the shop
a few weeks back that there was a team
that was interested
and backed out late in the 2020 free
agency process
and brady's reaction was you're sticking
with that mother bleeper
brady says that that's something he uses
for private motivation he's not going to
make it public
never mind the fact that he's already
made it public
he's stopping short of making the names
involved
public but he says they know who they
are and there's been so much speculation
about who it is and i knew brady was
never
going to actually address it i'm glad he
was asked the question
because i thought there was a chance
that he ultimately would never be
so we now know that he knows and the
team knows
and the mother bleeper knows and brady's
not going to say anything more about it
as we expected another thing brady
discusses
in that session with jim gray the
possibility of playing beyond the age of
45. now
earlier this week there were quotes from
alex guerrero
tom brady's personal trainer tb12
that brady's got two more seasons brady
himself has said i've got two more
seasons but brady
made it clear that once he gets to that
point once he finishes
the season during which he chan he he
will turn
45 and he'll be 44 as of august 3 this
year so
my math skills good enough to tell me
that next year at this time he'll be
turning 45
into that season supposedly end of his
career he says he'll
evaluate where he is at that point and
make a decision but if he can still play
at a championship level and it fits with
his overall life obligations
he could keep playing and we can't rule
out
frankly the possibility of brady
going somewhere else after
the 2022 season you can't rule it out he
said before i've got two years on my
contract with the buccaneers i'm going
to play two more years
he talked about going back to foxboro
and he said this is
probably the last time i'll play there
well it's definitely the last time
unless you're going to change teams
because the buccaneers won't be back
there for several more years
so yeah it's it's definitely the last
time he's going to play in foxboro
unless
after the 2022 season tom brady decides
to
pick another spot and try to win a super
bowl with
a third franchise which would not be
surprising if he pulled it off but it
would make his
historic career even more historic and
likely unmatchable by anyone for however
long the nfl happens
to hang around so don't be surprised if
he keeps playing
beyond 2022 and i'll add to that don't
be stunned
if at the end of the day he decides
maybe i'll give
another team a spin maybe there's
another team out there that will be more
stacked and clearly in need of him to
come in there
and shake things up and do what he
managed to do last year in his first
season with the buccaneers all right
i i saw that cowboy's
owner future owner he's got a bunch of
titles stephen jones the son of jerry
jones
said that the biggest mistake they've
made as a front office was not signing
quarterback dak prescott sooner and he's
right he's absolutely right
i'm just glad he admits it so many times
there's something that's obvious
but ego pride whatever
prevents people from saying what
what everyone else knows and maybe
that's why stephen jones said it because
everyone else knows now i doubt that
jerry jones would say jerry jones would
say
we did this at the right time this it's
a
lame impersonation i was kind of half
trying to and not really trying to
because i knew it would sound more like
ross perot but regardless jerry would
say we did this at the right time
we did everything just right this was
exactly what we planned to do
no and this is the message
to all of the teams out there this is
the flip side of the carson wentz jared
goff cautionary tale
you don't want to give a guy a big
contract after three seasons at the
quarterback position
when maybe you're not 100 sold that he's
the guy
on the other side when you are 100 sold
that he is the guy
you don't want to screw around
especially if he wasn't a first round
pick
that's what made it even worse for the
cowboys on the plus side
they got four years of dak prescott at
bargain basement prices
but with only four years to free agency
which meant franchise tag last year
second franchise tag this year maximum
leverage for dak prescott because
next year he would have gotten a 44
raise over this year's ridiculously high
franchise tag salary
they had to do that deal and because
they didn't swoop in
the moment the window opens and remember
the window opens
upon completion of the third regular
season not
third post season or third full year
you don't have to wait until the start
of the league year in march the minute
the gun sounds to end the last game of
the player's third regular season if
it's a drafted player
any round that's when you can go in and
sign them to a new contract and i said
time and again they should have had a
package ready to go
and you still got playoff games to cap
your third season you still got injury
risk you've got one more year of your
contract you don't know what's going to
happen with your career
if they were sold on him then that's
when they should have swooped in and you
know what
maybe they weren't completely sold on
then maybe they wanted to see what he'd
do in a contract year
and then maybe they wanted to see how it
would go in his franchise tag year even
though he broke his ankle in week five
i i don't know if they were 100 sold but
based upon the contract they've given
him
based upon the fact that last year they
used the exclusive level of the
franchise tag it tells me they were sold
so the point is this for as far as we're
concerned right now
the browns and baker mayfield the bills
and josh allen
the ravens and lamar jackson if the team
is sold
then buy that guy's contract rights well
beyond
today if you're if you're not quite sure
then you let it play out you're taking
the risk for example baker mayfield has
an mvp year maybe the brown's on 100
sold maybe they want to see what he does
this year will he regress
like he did in 2019 or will he go to the
next level like we saw him doing the
second half of 2020.
if they wait and he goes up price goes
up
that's the risk now for the browns i'd
say
based upon what i've seen wait a year
for the ravens
i wouldn't wait i wouldn't wait i know
some people are not completely sold on
lamar jackson as a total package
quarterback i think some of that may
have something to do with the offense
they run
but the ravens have completely
reconfigured their offense for lamar
jackson they're sold on this guy
don't wait josh allen in the bills do
not wait i talked about that a week or
so ago i think they're playing with fire
frankly if they wait
on josh allen's contract because his
value is only going to go up
and up and up now is the time to making
an offer he won't refuse
and that's the lesson to be learned from
what
stephen jones has admitted about the
cowboys failure
once they knew that dak was their guy to
get that deal done because look
once you know that's what you want to do
every day you wait it's only going to
get more expensive
it's only going to be more complicated
because the closer the guy gets to the
open market the more leverage he
acquires
the harder it's going to be to convince
him to not at that point
roll the dice and see what happens
that's what dak prescott had as a
practical matter
he had one more year at the cowboys and
after that
a ticket to the open market with no
restrictions from the cowboys
and they needed to offer him something
that would get him to trade that in and
it took a huge contract to do it because
they waited
as long as they did dion sanders hall of
famer
making news as the head coach at jackson
state university
it was almost comical yesterday the idea
that he chastised a reporter
for calling him dion and not calling him
coach
well look dion claimed
because i'll never refer to him as coach
now and i think many others will
do the same he claimed that no one calls
nick saban nick
the reality is they do and think of the
interviews you've heard over the years
how
players refer to coaches they refer to
them
as their first name they'll refer to
them as their last name they'll refer to
them as their nickname
that's just the way it is and i think
the younger the coach the easier it is
that that happens but for dion
it's a matter i think of basic respect
respecting your elders
and i've earned this or whatever the
case may be i also think there's
something deeper going on because the
question was posed by a reporter
from the clarion ledger on the same day
that
another reporter from the clarion ledger
was according to the clarion ledger
banned from covering
the southwest athletic conference media
day
where dion spoke because dion
wasn't happy with a story that that
reporter had posted
about some off-field issues involving a
four-star recruit from dallas the
biggest recruit jackson state's ever
gotten
dion wasn't happy with that that
reporter was shunned
and i think the other reporter who dared
call dion dion
was called out
i think in part because dion was looking
to pick a fight
with someone from the clarion ledger
because
he doesn't like the fact that they wrote
a story he didn't like well
hey dion you better get used to that
you're going to get bad publicity
and you make it worse by retaliating
against the people who are the conduits
for the bad news what do you expect them
to do brush it under the rug i know it
happens in some
college towns but responsible reporters
will not do that
responsible coaches will not retaliate
because at the end of the day time
honored maxim
when it comes to dealing with the media
don't pick a fight with a guy who buys
his ink by the truckload
you won't win that fight over the long
term because they're not going anywhere
and there may be a time where things
aren't going well
and fans are getting upset and people
are calling for your job and
you prefer to have those folks on your
side that's just the way it works
so hopefully dion learns a lesson from
that
speaking of nick saban the guy who is
called nick from time to time
i continue to be fascinated by
his position on the decision of miami
dolphins in march 2006
to not sign drew brees he talked about
it again
yesterday and as we get farther and
farther removed
from 2006 the story becomes
more and more specific on this point
one drew brees wanted to come to miami
two i nick saban wanted drew brees
in miami three somebody else
specifically a doctor
kept me from signing drew brees and now
four this is the news that that saban
broke with his most recent comments
once we didn't get drew brees i decided
i'm getting out of here
we're not going to be able to win
without a quarterback we were nine and
seven and on the brink of the playoffs
without a good quarterback we get drew
brees we go over the top and the moment
we didn't get drew brees i realize this
isn't for me
i don't buy it i don't buy it i think
what nick saban wants to do
he wants to rectify his failed nfl head
coaching career
with the very basic and simple argument
if they had just listened to me and
signed drew brees
we would have become the team since 2006
the saints became now my first problem
with that is
it really undermines the work that sean
payton did as coach the saints
to get the most out of drew brees breeze
was part of it
payton was part of it if brees goes to
miami and plays for saban
who's a defensive coach who's going to
get the most out of drew brees
is it going to work in miami the way it
worked in new orleans
saban just wants to assume that
drew brees wherever he would have landed
as of 2006
is going to unlock all of these
achievements and performances that
that made him one of the great
quarterbacks of all time i i don't know
that it's automatic now maybe it would
have happened everywhere else
but i think we can't underestimate
the contribution to bree's career that
came from sean payton and how
those two together created a magical
outcome that that caused sustained
success
in new orleans pretty much constantly
since 2006 with the exception of 2012
the bounty gate year
and then the effort to rebuild the
defense after the bounty gate year they
were still competitive
offensively even when their defense was
horrible once the defense caught up
you see what they've done every year
since 2017
2017 18 19 20 great teams in the regular
season
and but for bad calls bad breaks bad
whatever
may have been back to another super bowl
and and that doesn't mean the dolphins
would have become that
and that sabin would have been happy in
miami and would have been content to
stay there year after year
i think that in lieu of going back to
the nfl
and proving that he could thrive at that
level he just wants people to conclude
oh nick would have been good nick would
have won a super bowl he doesn't have to
go back and win one
enough people are going to believe nick
would have won one my other
concern is this
and and it's it's funny to me that you
know nick saban a guy who always has to
control all aspects of a football
program he's willing to create the
impression
that he really didn't control the miami
dolphins when we all know that he did
the idea that one doctor said
we can't sign drew brees and that nick
saban didn't have the power
or the ability to overcome that doctor's
opinion
tells me that nick saban agreed with it
because if nick saban wanted drew brees
there drew brees would have been there
nick saban said yesterday that dr james
andrews who performed the operation
on drew brees shoulder said that he
should be fine okay
if you've got some sort of an internal
thing and you don't inherently have the
power
to tell the doctor who said we can't
sign drew brees sit down and shut up
you're not paid for your opinion on
personnel matters we'll go forward thank
you for your
medical advice but we know what we're
doing if he isn't able to do that
at a minimum what you do is you go to
wayne heizenga who was the owner of the
team at the time
and you bring dr james andrews to miami
and you have andrews explain to heizenga
why andrews thinks
that brees will be fine because whoever
the doctor
is that said no chances are wayne
heisenga is going to listen to
dr james andrews and say yes and at the
end of the day
i don't think there's any dispute is the
ultimate authority and if you throw on
top of it
saban's position assuming that what he
said yesterday is true
that when they didn't sign brees that's
when he decided i'm getting out of here
well if saban had said to wayne heisenga
look wayne i feel very strongly about
this we need drew brees
i'm willing to take the risk james
andrews tells me he's going to be fine
and let me tell you this
if we don't get drew brees i'm leaving
after this year
this is it for me i mean if wayne
heisenga knew that of course he's going
to sign drew brees
of course it's going to happen because
they still got a quarterback
they traded a second round pick for
dante culpepper they decided
to take the guy who was coming off of
the serious knee injury and give up a
second round pick
over the guy who was coming off of the
shoulder injury
serious but still rehabbing just like
culpepper was
they could have had breeze for no second
round pick he was a free agent
they made that decision and the idea
that nick saban was just a bystander
while somebody else controlled the
decision i reject that
it goes against everything we've ever
known about nick saban he's not going to
take that
if he wants brees he's getting breeze
and people ask why do you keep talking
about it because saban keeps talking
about it
and the problem is no one's in a
position to call him out about it at
alabama because they don't care it's 15
years ago
but as long as he keeps talking about it
i'm going to be here
to scrutinize what he has to say and
and give you the audience the real truth
and the real truth is
saban could have had brees and i think
saban still would have left
miami anyway possibly after the 2006
season when alabama
came calling because of course i'm not
going to be the alabama
coach which is what saban said a few
days before taking the job
last point before i look and see if
there's any good questions today i don't
know if there are there aren't
i've been reluctant to write anything
about cole beasley's return to twitter
yesterday
responding to tweets making an offer
that he'll get vaccinated if pfizer
donates a percentage of whatever money
it's making from the vaccine to his wife
mark cuban had a response to that
beasley's been picking other
fights or at least engaging in debates
on twitter i i
and i don't i don't want to continue to
give the guy a platform
for a position that i believe
substantively is incorrect
i believe everyone should be vaccinated
i believe the only way we're going to
get past
this pandemic is for all people to get
vaccinated
and and to care not just about
themselves like hey coven's not going to
make me sick kova's not going to kill me
i'm young i'm healthy i'm fine
i'm worried about this vaccine well but
you could pass cover to somebody else i
mean we've been down this road
for the past 15 months i think there's a
dividing line here between the people
who only care about themselves
and the people who care about everyone
around them and the people who care
about us collectively getting past
this i think that's the bright line here
but
with beasley the point i want to make
today is i'm starting to wonder
if he almost wants to set himself up as
a version of colin kaepernick where
maybe he senses
that the bills aren't real happy about
this
and maybe he's in jeopardy of being cut
and maybe he just wants to be maybe he's
going to go all in with it
fine cut me and if no one else signs me
then then i'm the anti-vaxx version of
colin kaepernick and he becomes a fox
news superstar although fox news
at least some of the hosts starting to
sing a different tune about
vaccinations i just i feel like beasley
has something else going on here it just
seems like unless he's completely
reckless
and no one's explained to him you know
if you keep tweeting this stuff it's
really going to affect your ability to
make the final roster in buffalo
uh unless he's just careless and hasn't
made the connection and no one's tried
to advise him on it he can't help
himself if there's a strategy at play
it almost feels like his strategy is you
know what i'm going to go ahead and be a
distraction i'm going to be
disruptive i know they're going to cut
me anyway go ahead and cut me
and i'll move on to something else and
i'll become
for the right and i hate that it's a
political issue
but i'll become for the right when it
comes to vaccines what colin kaepernick
became
for the left neither of those should be
political issues but the reality in
today's america is everything some way
somehow
becomes a tool for recruiting
and or preaching to the choir let's see
if the choir has any good questions
for today stephen monk
any chance the nfl goes to a neutral
warm weather site for the conference
championships that way they could
go to the president's day super bowl and
lessen the chances of a mid-february ice
bowl situation i
don't see the nfl ever doing it i've
never heard any credible discussion
about
neutral sight conference championships
it's part of the home field advantage
that you play all season for it's part
of what the team that earns home field
for the conference championship game
has worked for and it gives that team an
an advantage
now does it put the best team in the
super bowl maybe not
but the team that has earned the right
to host that game
has earned the advantage that comes from
hosting that game so i don't see that
happening uh
cj newman interesting question what nfl
player or person have you spoken with
that made you think wow the voice does
not match the physical appearance for me
it's class campbell a lot of other
people didn't expect patrick
bombs to sound like kermit the frog
either i'd have to think about that
there isn't one that's jumping out at me
maybe there's one that i've forgotten
about
where when you hear the voice it's
shocking
and it's not what you expected i don't
know i'd have to think that through
there isn't one that's just i've been
carrying around in my back pocket yeah i
can't believe this guy talks like that
but uh
i'm sure there's been somebody over the
years where i've said wow that's a
surprise that that's the voice that's
coming out of that human being all right
um
daniel kunimoto if lamar jackson signs
an attractive contract extension without
an agent will be more players lined up
to start doing what he's doing i don't
think so i think that
most players understand innately that
the 100 that they get on their own is
less than the 98 97 99 percent that they
get
if they have an agent and there's so
many other things an agent will do to
help a player
guide his way through his nfl career
richard sherman and russell okung really
tried to start the trend a few years ago
and they were very
they were very vocal about it it's one
thing to say this is what's right for me
it's another thing to say this is what's
right for me and it's also what's right
for you
and that's what sherman and okung tried
to get started i think plenty of guys
understand
it's better for them to have help and
what's going to happen
is the relationships between
players and agents will now be created
and nurtured at the college level
through the name
image and likeness deals and that
is is what will in many situations
just become the natural precursor to the
nfl contract so by the time
the player is heading to the nfl he
already
would would have been working with an
agent and it's going to be a lot easier
for him
at that point to say i'm just going to
keep doing what i've been doing
jason jones with the nhl expansion draft
tonight for the seattle kraken
which two cities will get an nfl team
next and what will expansion
draft protection list look like i have
no idea how the nfl would handle
an expansion draft it's different every
time the priority that the new teams get
in the pecking order for the draft of
incoming college players is different
all the time
but you know i've always said the teams
that have had
successful franchises in the past are
teams are cities that we should look for
st louis and san diego the saint louis
lawsuit
probably will sour the nfl on putting a
team back there
however we have to consider the
possibility that a
settlement of the saint louis lawsuit
could result in some sort of a wink nod
commitment
that if and when the nfl expands st
louis will get
a team i think we have to at least
ponder that possibility because remember
when the browns announced their intent
to leave cleveland for baltimore and
there was some saber rattling about
litigation the end result was
cleveland gets a team a new team an
expansion team that will be the browns
that wasn't what art model wanted to do
he wanted to take the browns
to baltimore and make them the baltimore
browns and cleveland would have
been left high and dry cleveland ended
up getting the commitment that by 1999
the browns would be back with an
expansion team so
i don't know that that works in st louis
because staying cronky
is on the hook financially for whatever
the fallout is
of this litigation but i'm sure that
cronky
instead of writing a huge check to make
the case go away would love
to go to the nfl and say why don't we
just promise these people a team
and uh and then it won't cost me quite
as much to make this lawsuit
go away
uh let's see what else we have here a
question from idano40
when was the last time you watched an
old chris farley snl skit
that question's asked because i used a
chris farley gif from when he's uh the
motivational speaker
it's go time i can't remember when i
last watched one i think the last one i
watched was the
the the uh lay off me i'm starving which
always makes me laugh
but everything that he did was hilarious
i know the last chris farley thing that
i
actually watched was his entrance for a
david letterman
interview if you haven't seen that go to
youtube and get it it's
magical it's memorable and it will make
you start sweating
the amount of activity that you see from
chris farley in that minute or two
before he makes it from the back door
to the theater up to the stage i think
he takes somebody out and throws him
into a dumpster along the way but
there's a cartwheel involved or at least
something that looks like a cartwheel
but
uh that's fun to watch uh let's see
what else here we should probably we
should probably cut this off soon
question from yesterday
at milmost with cam akers achilles
injury the rams are in the market for a
running back to help fill the void which
free agent running back is the best fit
for their system and don't say todd
gurley because he's even more washed up
now
than he was when the rams let him go two
years ago you know the rams
after gurley and after that knee injury
dating back to college
after that knee started to affect him
remember it was late in the 2018 season
a year after he was the nfl's offensive
player of the year
the rams once they moved on from gurley
pivoted to the 49ers model of having
three
running backs who could come in and do
the job cam makers developed
throughout the course of last season as
the best of the bunch
now look their plan is to go next man up
now i think they'll backfill
with a young player but they're going to
hope the guys on the roster can
can do what they've already been
practicing to do in that new offense
with matthew stafford there as
quarterback
i i think that at some point
you know you could see a trade you could
see
the signing of an adrian peterson or
frank gore there's no way
todd gurley will be back with the rams i
don't think he'll want to go back and i
don't think sean mcvay is going to want
him back
but it's a huge issue whatever the rams
do it's not going to be as good as it
would have been with a healthy
cam acres because i think he was on
track to have a huge season
he would have been one of my breakout
players for 2021
and now that's that's a huge impact for
a team that is in such
a good division that is a huge impact on
their ability
to win the nfc west and position
themselves to get farther than they did
last year with jared goff at quarterback
this year with matthew stafford they're
going to need somebody at running back
to balance things out and make the rams
as good as they can be all right that's
as good as we can do
for today we'll be back tomorrow with
another hiatus edition of pft live and
pft
pm sources close to me tell me that at
some point possibly sims will be joining
me
for one of these which good news bad
news i don't know the only way to
find out is to tune in if and when it
happens but every day
every weekday even with the olympics
starting we'll have some fresh video
content for you
training camps opening exciting time for
the nfl
stay with us every step of the way at
profootballtalk.com and we'll see you
back here again tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports